all right A lot of people made New
Year's resolutions to get fit in 2023
and a good portion of those folks may be
second guessing that commitment we have
a couple of guests who say don't give up
just yet Jeremy Campbell is with us he
is from ivi performance he's being
helped out by Dion Hodges thank you both
for being here Jeremy tell me what do
you do at ivi thank you so much for
having us uh we are a dedicated personal
training and athletic performance
facility uh very private very exclusive
we tried to build a best-in-class
facility to bring the Best in Class
coaches together Under One Roof and
really Elevate the level of service in
the Vegas Valley in the personal
training world love it you guys just
opened up in November right yes sir we
did November 19th Southern Highlands
areas where people can find you what
will they expect what can they expect if
they visit you and start working out
with you well we're gonna meet them
where they're at they can expect TurnKey
coaching from us we say Best in Class we
mean deep Health coaching so we're gonna
look at all the areas of E-Life that we
can improve find out what your goals are
we're going to help you with some cheat
codes on that make things easier for you
to hit your goals all right and you and
Dion's joining us because uh you have an
example of some of the exercises you do
right well one of the things that people
struggle with in their resolutions Life
Starts to happen and they're compressed
with time I don't have the time to work
right so we just came up with a nice
kettlebell flow we had a little bit of
everything in the body don't need a lot
of time to get that heart rate up um
very simple to do you're a big fan of
the kettlebells I am yeah any modality
really but kettlebells are very easy to
use so all right let's show us what we
can do I expect coach Hodges is going to
start off to do what's called a pendulum
swing he's going to work his core here
okay so I'm going to have him kind of
hinge over he's going to stand it up
he's going to get into this nice hinge
position and he's going to go side to
side go one two so he's got a little
rotation anti-rotation here three two
one good go ahead and come on up he's
gonna set that down felt that the core
right Dion all right coach now we're
going to do what's called a flow so he's
gonna go a clean squat overhead press
tricep so we're going to hit pretty much
everything in the body here so he's
going to go down
he's going to come up get tall
so clean it get tall he's gonna get
small up over the head extend good go
back down and you say you meet people
where they are so if someone had back
injury or wasn't able to Hoist the 35
pounds correct you're gonna work with
him on that absolutely we'll do postural
stuff everything you would think about
with that yep all right you guys cover
it all including nutrition right 100 yep
it's a big part of the uh big part of
the ticket all right Jeremy Dion thank
you so much uh Rocky's going to cover
more of that
Kindle you really earned yourself a
thick and thin treat after that really
tough workout you just did oh beast mode
all right eye Hospitality has you
covered like you said in nutrition too
with their juice and Shake Bar located
right next to the IBI performance uh
building that you guys make it very
convenient for super easy super easy we
wanted to be able to service ivi for one
but also community and give them some
treat options so definitely not only
your healthy stuff but stuff for your
cheat day as well okay so what would you
drink after say a workout like that an
elite athlete like that would definitely
need to kind of have a whole meal after
so I would recommend the banana and
butter shake all right let's see um it's
a protein shake we have almond milk
already in there some ice we got a cup
of frozen bananas going in I'm a scoop
of protein so 25 grams of protein what
kind of protein this is chocolate weight
Big Brand guys are you ready to know for
sure and then obviously you want to put
a little bit of fat in there so we're
going to do a an ounce of almond butter
as well so let's scoop that in and put
that in there hopefully you like the
flavors of chocolate banana there we go
for sure for sure
animals
[Applause]
for sure there we go all right we're
gonna put this bad boy in there for you
okay and while I taste this tell
everybody how you also encourage and
allow cheat days absolutely so the other
half of our our concept is a treat bar
so ice creams and milkshakes featuring
your favorite cereals with either a
chocolate or vanilla base I'm pour a
little bit in there so you can go ahead
and try it first there's that here's a
shot for you okay that was a really good
sound take it back okay now tell
everybody how they can come visit you
guys visit us Southern Highlands um or
they can find us on Instagram a thick n
with an N thin treats
um yeah right on the corner of cactus
and Dean Martin this is delicious um in
Southern Highlands this is so good solid
I'm gonna finish this thank you thank
you this is so good and I love that you
guys can bring